- I'm strapped for time and very tired.
Why yes, that is exactly how I respond
when someone wants to sleep with me.
And also how I end up
making a favorites video!
(crash dong)
I haven't put up favorites video for
a little bit of time, and
so I thought why not now?
So I have a little favorites,
let's just do it now, with the words
and the showing.
First.
No.
Oh.
I hate choices.
(yells)
(inaudible noise)
This has been in a favorites
video before I think,
but it's back with a vengeance.
I'm avenging.
This is a perfume.
It's Elizabeth and James Nirvana Black.
I originally got these, in
the danger zone of Sephora.
The little mini sized
stuff by the registers.
I got Nirvana Black and Nirvana White,
and I like the Nirvana Black better.
Yeah I know you--
That was the universe stopping me from
making maybe an offensive joke.
This smells good.
This smells musky.
I was gonna say musty.
That's not the right way to describe
an order that you like, but if you like
musty odors that's great,
you like something.
This smells kind of musky, it
smells slightly more masculine
which is what I like.
Most perfumes to me smell
like soap that you bought
at the 99 Cents Store.
This does not.
This smells a little bit like
a man that hugged a woman,
that smelled like soap perfume,
but he also still smelled like a man.
This is good.
Next.
(inaudible noise)
This has also been in a
favorites video many times,
and it also has to deal with odor.
It is potpourri, if you do
not know I (cymbal zings)
love potpourri, it is a spray
that you spray in a toilet.
Before you take a (cymbal zings) and it
makes it not stank bad.
But this is my favorite
because potpourri comes
in these little travel sizes
that you can keep in your purse
and no one will know, that you
have a hugely, deep paranoia
about stankin up a bathroom.
Also, it kinda looks like
travel mace so it just
looks like you're trying
to protect yourself.
When really you're trying
to protect everyone else,
from your outrageous butt-hole.
Next.
(inaudible noise)
This is Smash box Camera
Ready BB Cream in light.
I love full coverage
foundation, but if I am wearing
foundation that isn't totally
full coverage, sometimes
I'll put on a tinted
moisturizer or some sort BB
or CC cream underneath of it.
As kind of a primer-ish thing.
And this BB cream from Smashbox
has really great coverage
that you could wear this
completely by itself,
and that's the purpose,
for girls that are super
comfortable with light coverage.
I like a lot of coverage.
I love (cymbal zings) on my face.
Do not use on damaged or broken skin.
Thank God, I'm definitely
not damaged or broken.
Next.
(inaudible noise)
These are Revlon Color
Stain, moisture stains.
I like my lipstick, like a
college boys sheets stained.
I am terrible at keeping
lipstick on my mouth.
And stains you've heard
me say in other videos,
are things I really love.
And these are really great
stains, that Revlon I think,
just put out maybe, not
sure I just noticed them
but l also am terrible at observation.
I also bought two of the same color.
Oh (cymbal zings).
This color is number 45.
It's called New York Scene.
Which gives you absolutely
no idea what color this is.
It's a dark red.
And this color is called,
number 50 London Posh.
Which also gives you absolutely
no idea what color this is.
It's a light pink.
Next.
(inaudible noise)
This is Dove Hair Therapy Dry Shampoo.
Actually when I lived in
New York, I bought this.
And for like six months
thought it was hair spray.
and have been using it thinking...
this is really (cymbal zings) hair spray.
Yeah it took me like six
months to realize that
it's dry shampoo, and
it's not meant to hold
curls in your hair.
It's meant to hold onto
the idea that your hair
is still clean.
I love dry shampoo period, I
really love this dry shampoo
because it smells really good,
and it works really well.
And it doesn't leave
the white residue that
some dry shampoos leave,
even if you scratch your head a lot.
Like you have lice of some sort.
Oh that smells clean and nice.
It just smells like nice.
It smells like safety.
If I smelled a woman or a
man, with this kind of scent
on them, I'd be like, they've never
even thought about murdering
someone that they didn't like.
Next.
(inaudible noise)
This is Kiehl's Cucumber
Herbal Alcohol-free Toner.
The only thing I like
alcohol-free is my toner.
The toner I bought a long time
ago, I lost it for awhile,
then found it, and have
continued to use it.
It probably is not good.
Does toner expire?
And it's got a bunch of
(cymbal zings) in it.
That seems like it's probably good.
And it's from Kiehl's
which I'm led to believe
through marketing, it's
like a very cool company.
For skin products.
It costs more then it should.
So it should be good.
The color's green
and like it doesn't apologize for that
so it should be good.
Next.
(inaudible noise)
Yeah I did buy a new pair
of UGG's for the season.
Eat (cymbal zings).
If you think less of me, please
avoid feces in your mouth,
if you didn't think less of me.
I thought I'd get ones
with laces in the front.
Because they look different
from the normal UGG's.
In theory, because the
laces make them look more
like boots then UGG's.
I could wear them with more
things and not be considered
a complete, basic (cymbal zings).
But, in reality, they
still look like UGG's,
and the laces just kinda
take longer to get them on.
Which defeats kind of the purpose
of owning UGG's.
But they're super cute and
comfortable once they're on.
Well there you go, they're
my favorites for right now.
I hope you guys enjoyed
them, if you did let me know,
if you didn't let me know.
Give me the thumbs up
though, either way because
in some countries, thumbs up
means bad so only this one.
And don't forget to subscribe
if you haven't because
that is a really fun thing to do.
I don't know.
(inaudible noise)
You can't see it, but you
can hear about it, and that
is HeyUSAx!
What does that mean?
If you don't know, Mamrie
Hart and I have done
a series called HeyUSA.
It's a really fun travel
series that we've done
for two seasons, and
now it is branching off
into another series called Hey USAx.
A more extreme sports and stunts version
of HeyUSA, and you're probably wondering
is it hosted by us?
(cymbal zings) No.
Extreme and Grace Helbig
and Mamrie Hart do not go,
in the same kind of category.
However, we found two amazing
hosts for it, that I think
you will love, and that
is Cody and Marcus Johns.
Look at those guys.
They're brothers, Viners,
Youtubers, social media
extraordinaires, just
basically like more handsome
and more intelligent and
more charismatic then
Mamrie and I are.
And more dumb because they
agreed to do this series.
In which they go to a lot of
places and do a lot of stunts.
That they don't know about yet,
and like HeyUSA, it is
very socially interactive,
so make sure that you go follow these guys
on all of their social media outlets.
So that you can weigh
on where they should go,
and what they should do,
throughout the season.
HEYUSAx.
Yay.
Finally, I'm promoting something x-rated.
Did I? I did.
We'll both see each-other out.